[Applause]  or i should say in the half  as clarkson has helped  fuel a 10-3 run over the last two and a  half how about that  broken ankle wow caught the rim put it  down  i mean he just blew by carter williams  he's got a gift and that gift is to  score a basketball  nonstop is jordan clarkson he has easily  won the battle thus far with terence  ross  he's outscored ross 16-6 in the battle  for the sixth man well i got a little  discussion point  after you know here's clarkson he gets  fouled watch it watch it  his moves spin move oh williams goes  down  amazing play he sticks out the tongue  but you know i'm gonna go back to the  mobamba right he he  terrific minutes and all of a sudden  he's out of the game buchevik back in  if you're brooklyn and you're sitting  there saying you know what we need a  center we need a backup center we need a  guy  would you not be just dying to get in  the trade deadline and trying to see if  you can make something happen  uh if